and welcome to top 16 of first attack
2019
I am Rindge this is Romanova we are here
with the dragon ball fighters of course
and why don't we got to start with this
game Romanova this is so close to my
heart we got super noon versus panda
global Nakia
for the first match of winners top a
qualifiers yeah I might need some of the
heart attack medicine that they gave to
Goku all right I need something I'm
gonna need the tissues I don't know
because I mean either way it's a win but
either way it's also a loss right one of
these guys is gonna be falling to the
lower bracket I'm not sure what super
noon spilled on the top of his shirt but
he's gotta get that cleaned up before
getting on stream man oh come on bro
come on bro you're looking like the
knees right now oh my god alright let me
stop let me stop but anyway let's get to
the match supermoon and usually Nakia
has super noonas number right seven even
three to the scenario I'm talking about
these guys are training partners super
noon has gone to New York multiple times
that stayed at Nikhil's house and has
grinded with him time and time again so
we're gonna see who actually moves on
the top eight winners and who's gonna
have to battle it out in the lower
bracket loser saw oh yeah we got that
boo be boo starting out - oh yes
kiddo boo mirrors now both of these
players have actually been playing boo
for a while I remember Mackey all being
one of the first kid boo players that I
mean he's gone back to the kid he's
looking great on him all tournament
right I'm setting wah wah - oh you can
call it upset just because Wall was on
Raw has like more strength to knock yo
the current state of Dragonball but at
the same time not the US had his number
and not because gonna be the first one
to strike here what hit for team grape
here taking them into the corner
the frame kills and then he goes into
the auto combo look like it was the
second hit of the Otto Hahn was also a
scaling like a medium yeah both your
sister on deck here Gohan assists going
into one boo and a level one for now
yells Gohan which is a good place to be
sitting at here exactly you know Nakia
wants in that combo with a love look
this way he gets the enhanced Gohan
truly mystic at this point doesn't
confirm with the vanish there oh pretty
back - into the - H Cohn super noon get
a little antsy right there and this is a
great strap from knock y'all right you
can see I'm just keeping his face cover
iam something says but super noon dodges
it doesn't convert the side switch
though catching the tag very fortunate
from super noon here but you argued to
ban so he's not gonna use it the snap
frames great reflect from nappy oh yeah
I was a little scared he gets to H right
there because of how long the raw tag
lasted they are committed to the rough
flag super noon doing the head again
this is super huge man been that way
since long
oh not trying to deal with any of that
see that's the thing right super noon a
veteran Kip do player himself he knows
he options after sparking what kicking
players want to go for so he just super
dances right through the key blasts and
actually caught him bashing on the other
side that was super smart
oh yeah he's getting this enhance level
three here super same for Goku
what's the mix gonna be after okay great
reflex but that tag and I don't know
about that that's you eight yeah meter
penalty ensures that he's not gonna
build a bar for the Vantage and snap out
talking about
nice I'm able to tag him out because of
the Zohan assist they have spark up now
super doing doesn't want to take this
mix either while that says elastic and
holds it to aims on the other side super
noon so if we're doing scouting out
these vanishes from knock yell perfectly
then be able to take down the kid boost
awesome sparking time as well meteor
advantage he has turned the game around
the good thing is get him out of the way
here this is a really good place to be
sitting because Bardock will not have
that lockdown assist exactly and not you
know able to open him up with the dragon
rush it was a good luck I see when
you're on the empty low but he couldn't
survive for that long and that to age
right there I love the knock yo combos
to the gold on Smith is so clean gonna
be able to kill it got a meter spin
those optimal
and now yell he's been playing go on
since forever so also great to see him
still playing this character even with
some slight nerves but still being a
very strong character in that game but
super dude is gonna get this hit only is
barn up remains but he is sitting on a
pretty four bars here go right to that
level three no surprise there he's gonna
be able to knock down in the corner Oh
shout it out bad - wait for him to
vanish shot and there it is I feel it's
those early morning jitters you just got
that the vanish button on on Dennis
there yep you know couple of drops um
some vanishes it's definitely a security
blanket for Dragonball fighters players
100% can't always just try and be
reflecting oh try to fight like their
first I meant great diagonal beam and a
Bucky in the air so could it
you didn't believe in that didn't
believe in that super - happy hour just
trying to find so even though GT Goku
clearly a strong character not
necessarily the best character by
himself
yeah I think that's what a lot of people
have highlighted as his biggest weakness
rise don't see you've knock yelping
overcomed at this point attempt Auto
comma does not chase him down close
enough and I got a stack of the pressure
a little bit already gets flipped by the
key blasts and throws it up with a 5/8
you have using the ACE look at the
ground bounce and the one bar will do it
super noon takes the first game very
close very very close there are a couple
of missed opportunities there for nack
yell to try and close that out himself
but again I just think that the better
character by himself there in that
situation was definitely a Super Bowl
party yeah for sure
Bardock an incredible character whether
he's on the assistant he's on point or
solo does not matter how close these
guys play against each other right you
can see how familiar they are with one
another at super nude is the 2hf a star
that's in the story of the set so far
[Music]
three bars with the dead kid boobs keep
that chest level one then all the way
through you know and it's wild because
the last game we saw the opposite at the
beginning with not y'all taking out
super Nunes kick you really fast and
sooner was the one that ended up winning
the match right so we'll see if not yell
can bounce back and he gets you the 5l
to start it off yeah let's see if we can
get a level of a so on always good place
to be
there we go we're level up I like the
variation on the wake up time in super
noon and then he gets the raw tag now if
you actually with a couple of the
instant air - is allowing that gap for
the tag to exist the great equalizer the
kid buu is since everybody's weak to the
falling mix up this time super noon goes
empty long okay you just break out of
that combo there goes for the diagonal
be no notice this up just yet don't want
to cysts gonna be available soon again
but super noon sittin on Boca sit down
maybe try call the kid buu as well but
he's putting it off screen Wow swing it
with the auto combo and it connects ya
know it's beautiful and he was just at
the right distance to still connect that
Oh
mr. Oliphant boy extension right there
you can call go home really late and
still get it not you have the slight
missed time in there okay I like with
the late wake up there or not it's the
super damn mean the other carry on back
towards the corner occasion if you look
too far you had to get the Gohan
extension so he just goes with the - age
knocked out yes we're in the optimal
positions well started with the 5 in
here he's got both assists on deck as
long as he completes the combo there's a
dead go home oh yeah here we go spear
bomb he's gonna need the dragon rush
extension and the little one after I
still think you actually might live
with the kid through that's smart yeah
the lower damage on the go-to for GT
just gets him out of there brings in the
kid buu instead bigger damage smarter
play yeah things are looking really good
for super noon right now all three
characters Raphael only with the
sparking and GT Goku we're snapping out
though we're bringing in the other pika
Goku who knows this has been a problem
for him gonna have enough I think to
kill here as well with the duck oh yes
yeah he won't even need to spend a meter
after you think he used the dragon rush
as long as he gets the level to do this
yeah
powered up version yeah it's gonna do
enough damage to kill them off here
without any follow-up necessary of
course GT Goku getting that power of
level 3 and level 1 once one of his
teammates is dead
of course both being that at this point
for super to fight with one character
broom on even ground very smart from
knock ele also has its marking on day 2
the dragon rush very smart move here
from Mac yelling yeah this takes two
inches the better okey knockdown didn't
cover the up tech
these mystical with the h dragon noon
this is a big hair right because he's
wasting some of the sparking time he
also has far darkest is he gonna set up
the mystic ball make somebody gets the
hit again this could be easily enough to
kill here just a level one in the level
three even with the sparking still going
super noon takes it to over na Kyo you
can tell us extremely close set both
very familiar with each other sparring
partners again knock yell has hosted
super new multiple times in New York has
grinded hundreds of matches with each
other and you can see just how that
played out
yeah you really hate to see a match
between two friends but it happens at
this point in brackets when you are the
top players this this is bound to happen
exactly if it's not against like you
know a lot of them are roommates right
so we got a sonic Fox that's normally
here Mac yells to kill sage and then
like you said they invite people over to
their house no yeah it's and speaking of
another battle friends we have to kill
sage going up against apology man now I
was talking to to kill sage earlier and
he was saying that apology man is
somehow always his like his demon and uh
when he meets him at the end there you
know like he says he doesn't know if
he's actually going to beat him right
now so we'll have to see if he can rely
on the power of square yeah we shall see
of course if you got them to kill sage
emos in chat please please give him your
power but in general right the kill
stage taking thunderstruck overall first
place I don't think he had to run into
beneath their Sun Oh beneath was there
but I think they actually had a plan for
I think I think they did yeah so because
the kill sage dodged even their God
first place that he's a bit generally
considered to be one of the strongest
dragon ball players in the United States
so was he being keep riding that
momentum of course taking first place at
a 10k EG event already he's got plenty
of points but he wants more wants to
ensure that he gets into the finals we
got happy sage and
a very happy looking apology man which
is it surprising me right Paula g-man
usually looks like he's just kind of in
the zone in the zone he's a meditating
like piccolo oh I see okay true no he's
a adopted that the namekian techniques
yeah I don't know if he could do a
special beam cannon in real life one day
what they believe maybe one day aim for
the stars
he's gotta go balls first
just like Niccolo oh god yeah now save
Jim was talking about how there's like a
whole like bald man gang like in that
you have to worry about joining that
team as well no I mean if I melt my hair
off maybe but like you know voluntarily
join terribly join but yeah he was
talking about it he was saying like
vicious is a part of it yeah Wow okay
vicious I wonder if we're probably not
gonna have a button check with these two
I don't feel like saying just one of
those I got their game faces on yeah
looks like we're getting right
Wow or is it across uh quite get in
range Wow
speaking of giving rage apology man with
the store normal from long distance
going right into this help it up
goodnight - oh that's nap Metta you got
to be careful about a puppy's here pick
those really good at bugging people not
gonna get at that but gonna have to be
scared that'd have to be scary being
girly against a simply appalling events
piccolo oh yeah and again now snapping
in the teen gohan see if you can survive
the hell's on your name big stuff does
not hit someone the dome as soon as he
lands absolutely abusing to kill fate in
the corner right now how long is the
kills Hayes gonna play this game before
he sparks their status yeah I I think
it's smart especially on Crowley you
don't want to deal with that yeah most
definitely nice possum apology man
including the instant air dashes after
the 6mz send enough for the grab I'm
thinking that he's trying to condition
him right now yeah out of it
what a great he just gets hit again and
the sparking is gone so - Kissinger is
just gonna have to hold this or hopes
that he makes the right move whether to
reflect or not incredibly impressive
start from apology man here going right
back into the game
dingo heart or kill sage lady for the
higher laws yeah we talk about
conditioning think he was gonna have to
like block low or overhead there and he
gets crabs not what's he gonna do to the
rolling actually takes the hit this time
apology man getting both those assists
bag including yeah that goal cruise
super Saiya june doesn't look leaders
fuzzy then jumps out of the line
wrapping cannot escape this corner
[Music]
special beam cannon enough damage with
just one bar on that berry last hit one
character down Brawley on death's door
and no sparking fatigue as somebody
called see why is that was childish nice
going right into the teen gohan for the
proper extension here is gonna be able
to kill him off with two level ones
right back in a piccolo as well man
apology man is rolling he's barely
touched right now by to kill stage which
is insane trying to catch them we're
going out but apology max has been
solely solid on defense I like the
challenge for the piccolo beam or the
piccolo ball with the key blasts from
Goku getting rid of that quick okay
going privilege jump it oh okay those
foods I see black but gets blown up here
the corner beneath is gonna spark great
option right there from beneath right
because if you get hit by the 6m then
you're negative so he just goes for the
reflect obviously comes out in one frame
breeze it and because of that he was
able to look like the two H and the beam
on the other side and the vanish which
means guess what
pull punish level three into the level
five that's going to be Game one
like it's yeah
what a strong game from apology man
there he woke up he had his cereal with
his warm milk and he is just ready to go
he just put the ball outside I like the
heat of warming up spark up the promises
you made to kill state angry yeah you
stepped on Android 16 head in front of
them Auto combo catching the raw tire
out there just teen gohan things yeah
great back - you picked up team go on
after I pick up teeth Gohan it's true
but let me remind you welcome down again
have blossomed the whole players
yeah the killings looking for something
you saw the countering a notification
maybe you thought that uh Denise was
gonna respect to come back off yeah not
and we are playing the snap role he gets
home the air-to-air you have another
counter hit the kill sage trying to find
his way out just the lonely
he doesn't have Sparkie to get out of
this horror situation I don't think
we'll see pickle he'll come out this yet
but it might see a super here no I keep
snapping it seems like a good idea
though it goes for the lone beautiful
stuff locking them down with the goat
Cruces making them guess I'm gonna get
right back into it I feel like - like
apology pants team it's one of those
seems like mid-range said okay but it's
a corner just it's just so hard to deal
with and you're seeing that right now
with the kilt babe what did set up with
that hell's on after he's gonna be able
to reflect all of it
not like Bethel apology man just backing
up waiting for the raw attacked with the
kills aged one step ahead not giving it
to him safely gets Broly in here we go
right to the level three with Crowley
wait I thought he was waiting for the
wrong - no - Asian the gills Asian lady
gets heated up by the legs you saw the
flash of armor as well he tried
something - a bra liba man the legs have
so many hits and he just got hit right
over the don't with those legs they are
literally the new shotgun of this game
well not even knew they statement they
bent shotguns they just had to put him
back on the character selection he was
banned for a little bit unsuccessful
it's good to see that kills a stick it a
little bit of that blue health back from
when he pulled out pink go on try for
the demon elbow only finds the lows from
the kill sage knock down all right at
least pick clothes out of the way here
but to kill Sage has a long road ahead
of him if he still wants to take this
game against apology man but that auto
capo why isn't he in the corner after
that as well pausing as doesn't Spartan
got to keep that in mind can't convert
off the team Gohan is this choice
they're all the drops the combo there he
has a big damaged starter if I can make
the most of it
oh great reflect punish therefore the
guilt stage I was soul clean that
multimatic playing a little reckless
here because he has that sparking he's
gonna lose what his characters because
of it it's a scary place to be even with
that sparking still left because Super
Saiyan Goku is a survivor
oh yeah he's not gonna give up
I got apology man finally carving that
spark with the T Gohan again this is the
newest addition to his team the
character he's the most experienced with
what's the other side while you try to
anciently trying to cover his whip with
his own advantage and that is a habit a
lot of Dragon Ball fighters players have
you see them with you just gotta wait
they will vanish and to H citty
jump it double axe handle that same
lineage paying off it's all about the
kill station binding this nexus marking
has gone for apology man would take at
least two hits here both players go play
real two splendas point at the key blast
rocket legs to the face this could
easily be death right there
an apology man's gonna take it over to
kill sage sending him to the loser side
of the bracket and that was a winners
qualifying match no apology man gonna be
in top fate winners scythe that's a good
look for him and you mentioned before
the match right that kills sage talked
about an apology man being his demon
having a like one of the worst
tournament records against him as well
like the overall players are concerned
and man could see why apology man just
seems to have his number
he really has him on his watch he was
ready for everything and to kill sage
just for how experienced of a player
that to kill sage is he just really
wasn't able to get out of that corner no
matter how much he tried especially in
that first game it was like he got one
chance on offensive momentum and apology
BAM blocked everything and then jumped
out of the throw and as soon as that
happened he took his momentum back
sparking was gone you had no resources
to get out because that's what this time
meta brings right we talked about it
yesterday the only resource you have
once you get a character snapped in it
is the sparking on defense you can't
guard cancel you can draw a tag you
can't do any of that so because of that
the snap minute is very strong forcing
to play with one character an apology
man plate it's a perfection and
especially with the character like
piccolo
when he's the one on your you know
offense yeah it's just so so rough so
rough no looks like we have up here we
have no call me and subatomic savers
this should be a fun one no no call me
we seen him switch his team giving up on
the bay Android 21 no longer is she or
go he blacked on his team he has gone to
the dark side Indian and this is an
update for the option key matches
happening and losers top 16 shanks has
defeated honey badger so I believe he'll
be qualifying for top male ooh sorry I
think it's play one more match actually
I think to qualify for loser site top
eight he's gonna have to plate the kill
sage the kill sage oh man that is that'd
be a heartbreaker for me because they
thought that's happened before and I
think the kill sage has beaten him
mm-hmm I always chalk that up to the
kill site - played Android 18 for a
while so he probably has that experience
with knowing how to blow up like the
gimmicks that she has oh yeah subatomic
it looks a little sleepy and then of
course no economy on the other side we
talk about no economy a little bit
yesterday making top eight evil 2018
it's kind of falling back in terms of
results - Dragon Ball fires he's had a
couple of good showings here and there
but he's proven then he can hang with
the big dogs and again he's here in top
16 winners side trying to get a fat
chunk of points at his tank ihe event to
qualify for the finals and beautiful
france we are gonna see some vegeto
action ya subatomic savers I think plays
an unorthodox team here in 2019 right we
got cell and go tanks on the squad still
two characters that have fallen out of
favor 50 you know also a little bit
underrepresented by man he really makes
this squad work like nobody I've ever
seen
he really does and yesterday we're
seeing so much so many great things
of him when he was using go tanks he was
using the shop cancels yes it was I was
getting most of his opponents like
almost every time that we had a on
stream playing about and a great jump to
start things up again summertime it was
the one that sent shanks put losers
yesterday people playing is very low
this weekend
he played and seen leave strong against
them to Oh get some lockdown don't think
justice here gonna get that pit now
that's it's them a little bit of a
deceptive start up looks similar to some
of these other normals but again it's
been paying off a subatomic I feel like
the key here for no commie okay the
sparking was gonna help him get out of
that corner positioning but he's gonna
have to be careful and be patient when
he's playing against subatomic savers
because I feel like that's what his team
makes you do oh yeah exactly just put
you in these obnoxiously long block
streams and I like that summer topic not
gonna lend o-cana me get this momentum
Wow mystic ball hit the raw egg but he
can't convert off the dragon rushes
there brings right back in the cell
actually we're gonna look to try and
[ __ ] yep if he gets another point here
yeah but you got the hit below there and
we're gonna
see a little bit of damage here maybe
okay no he's not gonna go for any supers
try to go for a low that mystic ball
yeah of course subatomic plays against
super nude almost every we got a great
to age right there so he knows how to
get out of Istanbul Horner setups with
agar cancel as you saw now he's got
plenty of meter on deck this kid who is
damn that is a dead kid buu going right
so those cut probably to finish him off
well done sparking artis come on both
sides because they didn't want to get
their pony any momentum I think that's a
smart decision for no commie right
you're not gonna have a lot of
experience against up a sonic sabers or
design orthodox team so you've gotta not
let him get offensive right hit on the
other side yeah yeah right through right
there good punish from no Connie on that
okay we're gonna see a gank you Donna
hold your hands up to the sky got three
bars followed up they just gonna go cut
it mix-up oh and catches some reflecting
beautiful read from no Tommy yeah I mean
like empty jumped in there and just went
right into that dragon rush that's dead
go tank
bounces back from losing that character
he's like no Peugeot tanks and yeah
honestly the hardest toughest Tamaki
sabers team a lot of you will tell you
that I really do like the way that
subatomic still like that you played
fell and the way that he plays so yeah
this is not a good place to be though
for some and he's gonna get Dragon
rushed here by no commie five bars on
deck already for no commie you know
major gain is no problem right now
Grambling another genki-dama and that
means another mix afterwards how is no
commie gonna go if it works it works
yeah I feel like most of the time an
empty jump low is gonna work on those
people yeah micro - is what make you
think using it go on for that just an
air - across up but a great year there
from no Tommy LaBelle what a change of
momentum - we saw a subatomic Sabres
kind of looking a little stronger
beginning in this match a TOCOM he's
really picking it back up yeah he was
able to kill off that kid buu but he
really hasn't gotten a hit on no commie
sense that looks a little dirty the
plane he got a little bit of maybe a
cross up or just that super - was really
good yeah I think since he was a block
then from like the beginning he didn't
actually have a block cross up but I
definitely put him back to the original
side okay try to super - through that ki
blasts so vegeto is one of those
characters as well when when he's
fighting self and doesn't assist really
to cover ups it's not as much pressure
as he normally is because normally he's
relentless yeah
from subatomic as you mentioned got a
long way to go no assists to back them
up and yeah whipping the toss back yeah
it's really hard if he's not already in
the corner to extend these combos
Furnham it's not gonna be quite the way
that you're used to seeing vegeto be
played yeah for sure
I just saw him doing some five lights
out there got hit by that beam gonna be
the last of it and no commie takes it
over subatomic favors game one indeed
yeah I thought that 500 was actually
gonna hit Goku my man call me always
flashes a smile for the camera he's
definitely a showman oh he's he's
definitely a show man you know yesterday
he cracked me out man
he cracked me up yeah he was getting
perfect sand just laughing in the camera
man I feel you know calm me he's carried
that confidence that momentum he looked
real relaxed before the tournament I
feel like for him that's exactly where
he needs to be great star for subatomic
oh yeah I like to use them to jump up
into the sword that I feel like that
also like especially online
that's like the online vegeto classic
yeah I mean other than five like control
the ground with the go Luis is right
there though as a match to me know I'll
go thanks assistant to the advantage but
gonna get blown up therefore that
reflect with a2m the kid booth oh yeah
wake up - OS so the Congress neighbors
really likes to wake up with a it does
get him killed sometimes oh okay I like
that I like the tag and after those
reflex oh yeah we got the sell boots in
the corner ending up shortly going right
into that level three we are on the cell
Games arena right
that's funny no commie was forced in the
situation he sparked that's why he was
looking for the dragon Russ right there
but don't call me actually tech that
incredible defense press the two is just
the other side vanishes instead of two
Asian that could that could boo for that
opportunity but we got a tag out and we
got to change okay I like the jab just
not gonna matter the super down there
no vanish after that for no apology
alright Pacino's back on point here we
go going right into that snap bell
ringing kid boo trying to get rid of
that last bit of help and he's gonna get
it with this dragon rush showed him the
Galactic gonna don't call me thought
about blocking it just for the frames
that he got dragon rushed when the rings
are out yeah that's what he did but he
died for it Oh
aged a little bit too high on that super
- intent some of the time saver scouting
it out pause the back oh yeah go right
into that final kamehameha here in the
corner better get that knock down what's
gonna be after going great to the five
light gets sellout so that's a sparking
bait a lot of time when they do 5l for
vegeto you can do it and a lot of time
players wait to give them blocks done
right so because of that they'll do the
5l and then raw tag and the raw tag will
dodge the sparkle glass yeah I mean you
talk a lot about how great a player
subatomic savers is and doing that kind
of thing I think that is what makes just
one of those things that makes them such
a great player right
Chow's the childís vegeto as well from
New York I saw him doing that and OBC
this past week a lot of Agito players
got that strat on lock
don't wake up with that right into the
sparking that's a dead kid Goku I love
that from subatomic because he had no
beer to vanish or extend the combo
anyway else right so we spend the
sparking well worth it he's looking
healthy right now
this man's finishing his plate yeah he
always got those solo snack novels as
well that's you that I love seeing about
it go tank still - is he does the keep
laps into the down I it makes me almost
kind of miss the era of go tank for
somebody stuff that's how I feel about
so I got loved watching selamat yeah you
love watching someone he's not just like
completely making you walk for 12
minutes straight he's letting it rip all
over the place nice jump and but he goes
into a regular age instead of to a chomo
smash oh my gosh he keeps getting these
little edgier just knock him out of
stuff with that T blast that's gonna get
at least level 3 going here for no
commie with Super Saiyan Goku no he
doesn't spend it he does at the six bars
I'm very surprised but maybe he wanted
to keep that corner positioning
yeah there's applying the rail ergo
stakes pressure an immediate reflect all
jumps out at level three is not working
a button and super - punished you get no
meter to vanish and confirm didn't have
the assist ready either this is very
much a goes who worthy comeback is gonna
pull this one off I'll tell you that
much the same it again I guess I respect
it oh right Tek there on that yeah felt
like a last moment second nope Tommy
gets one kill if it's a mid for Goku but
still pretty quick yeah it's just quick
and it's great for staggers do you just
do that - up yeah if you get close
enough I think he's got great steyr game
with the lights right his 500 and it's
two of great tools for that way to
bounce back from subatomic though we're
going to a game three determine who gets
top ain't winter side trust lied in
there's nothing no comedy though
watching his legs from that distance
getting missed a ball roll out as well
as on atomic bonuses are back now
thought will jump out of the cell but
then expose himself press in a play here
we go
toss them into the corner all right this
is a great positioning here for
subatomic sailors great tech there from
there Tommy
gotta hold that after the good thing too
since both assists are down
sellers back on deck here we go got the
diagonal manages to get that hit with
the jump in yeah I know he thought
because it was kid bully when half the
block that second overhead lane you most
definitely does it's that like the
Napoleon complex interaction goals and I
believe what the sellers should be an
advantage sir I'm always a little wary
when it comes to the Gold Souk radar
because I know it's not that much damage
but let's get the job done all right
backs off itself I like I like the
spacing here that he's trying to keep it
this distance from GT Goku that is why
and he just got that dragon rush on him
we have enough bars here for a spirit
bomb as he wants to that City good yeah
don't call me not going for it he could
have done it solo as welcome to the four
bars but he gets the back of the neck
tap cross look jumping media
yourself
sends it right and snap out we're gonna
bring in Super Saiyan Goku now obviously
this was a really good character here
the last time you know Connie had him
out so it'd be good it would be a really
good place for subatomic if he can take
this character somewhat on the case
perfect attack that gives you access to
maneuverability once you get on the
other side and he just fakes the cross
of air dashes back and hits them on the
same side that's fantastic
yeah you always got to watch out for
that when summertime it glows with the H
perfect attack setups try to get the
cheeky dragon rush there right after
great conversion
energy field no he's gonna switch out
and go to the lumber one for vegeto to
close it out and bring him back on point
this this is such a better game than any
of the other games in this set for Game
three yeah
subatomic subatomic yeah really looking
like he's found the data that he needs
but no commie nice to Asian showing that
West Coast power that you guys talk
about I mean some atomic definitely want
to rise your stars of SoCal to say the
least
you see here enough both tanks you have
set up both of the low you hit him with
six um earlier I search on conditional
block the overhead there so try to move
yeah I like to calling out the Sela
sister bringing go tanks cuz look at
that we banks off of it all right we
have four bars built up I mean I was
just gaining with go tanks Oh
extended as far as possible knew he
needed every inch of damage he was gonna
get but his stuff was of and a great
with punish right there with the auto
combo yeah he was just kind of out of
range there no coms with advantage of it
there we go I'm gonna go into the spirit
bomb definitely kill off the go tanks if
he gets a successful mix-up here oh but
no he doesn't turn around for the jump
media it's unfortunate the 2l load
pushes and subatomic savers will be a
top eight winners side later on today
yeah that's well for the geo very potent
when it comes to like the meta of her
pressing buttons next to each other
right because you like to press that 2l
but the 2l from Patito low crunches
takes him into the air and then slams
him down you can see kuba the cell
cowboy also rush in the stage
today that like I think that should be
in the Dragonball Fighters World Tour
rules no dabbing multi-hued counsel to
make the rules to ban the dab but yeah
kuba if he's on stream later you will
definitely see him that but for all this
darkness that is subatomic sabers cool
was the exact opposite right you see him
rushing the stage dancin celebrated for
his boy so they have a nice balance
through sparring partners they play all
the time so he's definitely gonna be
happy for subatomic making that top
eight winners side getting some more
points to get into the finals yeah and
that's a really good place to be sitting
at you know shoutouts to him you you
believed in them but I think it's
because you also didn't uh you weren't
so you didn't ruin his good luck yeah
you guys haven't seen me compensate
subatomic matches before at these Dragon
Ball Tour events I usually hide them up
and then usually underperforms so I'm
stop that and look at that top eight
winners side good stuff
and next up here we got Japan's tachi
cow versus New York Chris G so Tachikawa
rocking the near mullet haircut here yes
a jam dubbed it the Joe Dirt which I
could no longer unsee yeah and I think
we said yesterday too if we said that to
him he would probably just say thank you
and like smile yes probably has no idea
what Joe Dirt yeah but he's rocking a
new team he's no longer rocking Frieza
18 or hits nah he's rocking what was the
GT I think is on his team he has Yamcha
teen gohan and teen go on yeah what man
is about that winning a character select
screen now but talking about Frieza
Chris G now playing Frieza so at least
we will get to see the lord himself but
this is definitely a button check we
know Chris G likes to warm up his hands
I was gonna say if you ever seen Chris G
match you know the hand warmers are
coming up first and again he's the only
one I give a pass to because he plays 50
games and I believed ya cuz this isn't
the regular Chris G team I believe this
is the regular Itachi Cal team though
ting go on yeah that is how she college
room right now and then chris has been
playing some freezes I talked to him a
little bit about it after Mexico I think
yeah after after thunderstruck and he's
where he got second overall but he was
talking about just how Frieza really
helps him enjoy the game a lot more he
really likes playing the character and
that's what he's been going with I
believe it was use I was saying he's one
of the ones favorite to kind of either
win this tournament right now yeah yeah
the kill sage tweeted his papers for the
tournament our Christian wha-wha
going into this I think wall wall was
the clear favorite of course he's and
losers bracket currently got put there
by Nakia Chris G also having tremendous
performances this year in Dragonball
fighters second that thunderstruck as I
said top eight at evil 2019 at the saga
event so we got a nice chunk of points
there but he's gonna get some more
points if he is able to get in the top
eight winners sighs yeah we got the
frieze of the GT go through and the yawn
show so yeah you know both players
rockin the GT goku and Yamcha in the
second and third positions but the
Frieza for Chris G course [ __ ] Kalla
has carried that Frieza flag for a long
time but has since put it to the side
and Chris G has picked it up I told him
to go bold in the field summer to play
Frieza again and he goes no no golden
[Laughter]
but like we've seen like I think it was
CEO that he had it come back
that was completely from his own soul of
Frieza left and he went golden Frieza
and smirking and it was like pretty
crazy from what I remember golden Frieza
my favorite stuff to watch in the game
it's great and if we're gonna see
somebody do it we're gonna see Christie
we were seeing him yesterday when he was
playing throughout the pizza this and
charge up those are that's one of his
favorite strats for sure Greek air
already from Chris G alright both
assists are down with Chris G's
second ones about to come back up there
gg-go could be a great place to be
didn't hit [ __ ] Kalla trying to keep
his distance but get the jump in
Tachi khalwa taking brief to the corner
here yeah hey I like the way Christians
been playing these a very heavy Frieza
style just back up I think I shot a low
profile to be honest with you based on
that clip yeah we're gonna see a snap in
bringing Frieza back in here tries to go
for the overhead great vanish ow gets
the super - in this stuff from Christie
so far now it's on a set up shop
staggering up the pressure but why
Chicago can't hit the block waits for
the disc coming back there we go now he
pulls other up like this time for the
super that you see them simultaneous get
the cross up super - in this extension
this is a good place for Christie to be
sitting here drops Afonso go but gets
punished on that snap oh you have held
the Vantage so he can get the pool combo
I think freezes classic oh it doesn't
drop this he's gonna have no but he
drops it right there oh don't eat that
nah that's that dad Frieza tachi towel
we saw him defeat Koopa yesterday as
well with that Yamcha reversal level
three you gotta watch out for
yaaasss if just backs up afterwards you
have surprises Oh for the conversion off
that gg-go who says maybe he wasn't
expecting it you know oh great
forward advancing there to get in they
would have the Optus is extension if he
wants it okay right just keep it on deck
for the post you can keep out my mix-up
it just feels like it goes so far yeah
member pete-r yeah they got that ha ha
it is gold you yeah there it is okay
great you to be on posters finally hit
the low here [ __ ] taller and good
positioning still waiting for the assist
to come back up but snapped out brief
and Yamcha goes below this is building
time to get those assists back finally
gets the Yamcha those block the empty
low here but you got block one more time
and the burial a overhead connect snaps
him out again force him to play with one
character in force on the spark
I like the switch to low they're
thinking that maybe he was gonna expect
him to overhead falls out the gap there
it goes right into that level 3 so this
is all right for Christie because it's
gonna be all blue life prices in our
look could be able to heal all of it via
the sparking I like the way that
Christie was able to avoid the offense
is there but Ginza will think this gets
his hit this is gonna be a good spot for
him spirit ball should do it they slowed
that down but still catching Tasha cow
or they'd be able to get that power
double born powered up level one with
the armchair level one
good place to be and just like that
those tables are pretty much evened up
here
both still have two Ianto cysts on each
team you know when they plan on using it
greatest sister halves don't want the
best in the game my opinion almost
definitely and yeah just the little
point character as well we see touch
Italo and finally a raw tag them out now
one of the things I noticed in the way
that the Japanese players are at least
watch Okawa plays teen gohan versus the
way the american players plan is taki
kala not really using and abusing the
auto combo yeah right he hasn't been
swinging for the fences like we see a
lot of the teen gohan players do TV
given that opportunity if you take say
bleep goes right into the entree in some
air - oh we're just catching Chris G
cotton right yeah go for anything
whooping fist here's you're gonna get
the knockdown off of this gonna go for
the jump in no go spring for dragon rush
right in front of I yeah I kept
themselves those the start up over
reflect or not by the way it does
connect and Chris Jesus at GT go through
his dead but man he is pretty clutch on
this solo Yamcha he's got seven bars
Toxocara doesn't have a lot of life and
a great age will think business start
the game level 1 into level 3 I think is
actually gonna kill here oh yeah
bring them close oh yes Chris G's
accessible this is good you know good
job for Chris G to make that conversion
and still spend that and clean his plate
there
and now we have the light fleet on top
of Hall and they both have equal amounts
of meter here
all right throwing out the key blasts
try super dash in and put some stuff
okay guard cancels out team Gohan was
above his head behind Yamcha and the
spinning mixer still got goodness the
hitbox on that yummy he spins around
dogs 360 wow yeah if you're touching
Cowell you got to make sure you don't
get mentally cracked over something like
that right you were so close to winning
the first game very unfortunate way to
play out for him Eric in from Chris she
definitely started the last game he's
gonna get more of a combo this time off
of it though a tomato you could safely
rather
why you might save it all right we're
going in here Frieza trying to stagger
some of these hips here try to get that
opening the key for this route gets the
low off that goes right into the heavy
no no talk about maybe trying to reflect
there you had a block crouching so
because of that I just really like what
I'm seeing with Chris cheese fries
especially like in the corner just
keeping that pressure but does back off
there gets hit by the key blast from
team go on lock it in the corner but
using that she make him block after the
combo and there's a Christian great
there - as well three actions on this
man have always been so good I like to
reflect on that last out of the legs and
main about the big jump now mocking
blocks done way to the corner again I
mean to be fair that is like Lord Frieza
ship right behind there right you right
you're a home court advantage
Chris you bring out the disc in now just
waiting for the rods ad flutters is
perfectly and gets the level three after
the Destructo this come on Chrissy how
you always so ready the marble brain he
definitely does his brain excels at
games like this he's able to take down
the GT Goku went from when wins Matylda
wins Dragonball yeah
all right yan presses down they're
taught to Paulo fine the hit go off that
jump we're gonna knock down we're gonna
change in the wulfing fist
here we go spending the three bars he
was looking for the if it's not broke
don't fix it strap but Chris D with a
quick adjustment let them lock down with
a yawn so there's hook if you go through
this is available for the yeah instant
and - makes up great tech afterwards
Chris Chris G just seen Hachi collar
trying to get on the corner there Chris
has been sold agent this game and then
guess the super - is he calls the
obtrusive gets both gonna do a lot of
damage here oh so smart those are three
four freeze that because it's one hit
right so he's gonna get the max damage
on gon shake even if the point character
dies quick barking you cannot press buns
on the destructor this is my friend
Chris chief topic winner side ya got
sucked into the vacuum of space right
there maybe this will make Tots maybe
this is revenge right now for tashi Kawa
giving up on Lord Frieza I gotta say you
know I wonder how thought Chicago feels
about that alright drop in the freezer
drop from the Android 18 picking up the
cheaper characters I'm more overall talk
to your team and then Falls to Chris G's
Frieza man I like that story I heard but
he's still alive he's just dropping down
into the loser's bracket because not
mate winners has been decided so let's
take a look at the braggy you can see
super noon versus apology man a tale as
old as time itself subatomic savers vs.
Chris G man this is a wild top eight
winners sign all the Americans in there
cuz as we mentioned before shanks are
falling to subatomic savers and knock
you out defeating hua while yesterday so
both of them are still alive but they
got to qualify through their losers
bracket but before we get to that we're
gonna take a quick break here on
twitch.tv slash dragon ball fighters
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
for the rest of top eight qualifiers
stick around we're gonna these wrong
come back for more
somebody's definitely taught the boy and
you imagine go easy going into losers in
top 48 something like shrimp water
though I manage all those trip guards in
this mess opposed to be worth something
but ok I see by Omega Zell cars go son
this self got wasted
yeah he got pulled me like what am i
doing power that was a bad job therefore
metal nothing still good but now he is
at the receiving end of summer freshman
oh oh
did the awesome oh but he dropped the
combo as well these are you attack too
early son messed up is me that sucks for
left me
I know he's not happy with that one you
know that's a stick slammer and it's a
look yeah absolutely
absolutely oh we can spark
you can't spark yes we will I think oh
we invade challenge them
nice little bit a little too fast to do
that was like the weirdest angle on
horrific attack you got him he got him
set us down that is a big important
piece of going to steam and it is debt
did he walk the wrong side I don't know
what each other to make each other hold
each other you big try to hop up that
tag because I wonder what was he getting
pushback by the eights by the pointy
ones this time so I said yeah that's a
good question because if he did he got
pushed back into across the situation
[Music]
there's so many things so many things
happening this mess yeah I I didn't see
the replay I like they stagger go alone
he's not being real autopilot assaulters
it's really trying to pick em out girl
are you gonna open up go easy all right
we got a final flash I agree so easy has
got it get back and control this match
pronto oh what a call-out trying to fake
the cross up but you know what he got so
regardless that's not a good look that's
a bad sign all right some sympathy for
kicking in now for sure Oh
give me them legs I'll take him all day
almost a birdie
oh shoot but that hated it it fix the
bow he put him in the course isn't that
crazy
oh-ho oh no we had about the photo we
don't take those don't you want no part
of that
oh oh oh he's family Oh going to
flirting with disaster here the eggs the
whooping that was so much talk on the
screen love it just kind of happens
let's go along with it go long I don't
think about the - well my brother Oh
take it to a stand-up it's funny
- it is hard not down Oh bother
you don't straight he actually wanted to
collapse literally diddle actually wanna
blast I don't know what happened they
fight it a little to me
like this so now he took the compote
ain't nervous they look the same now
host my daddy what then yeah why he's
gonna get what senator pepper that's his
favorite food apparently he has the
reaction of a 25 year old Xena Oh
string him up using the cellos and the
violin sign up gonna happen weapon is
going to sit
go easy two losers and top 4800 wait a
minute wait a minute let me get him
together
he got plenty of all we'd like to see
God brought aka Provencher assault of a
couple of times
hold on here we got some bars coming oh
no Paul my defeat another guy is he
truly the god and slave I think this is
a pretty good argument for yes oh my god
back up
they don't you what everything don't you
wait oh my gosh but they some nastiness
upcoming it go wake up s probably worth
the reflector oh my god for nuts tags
write this out let them write this out
for me the car came
put the stick right that's it
don't forget what that was a nutria that
jump serious to react to that stay solid
this man is in another plane of
existence galaxy brain interdimensional
work are you serious
he's keeping up in a steel bar boy he
has two bars for the next 15 seconds oh
the boys up for the slide a night man
ivory but no reversal for suddenly in
the work was this a possible that
without door but it does not get the
frame invaders off the vanish oh there's
45 seconds left on the clock and locals
go et has not let go of the back
position on this deck there is a zoo
pins are working overtime right now I
need a medical professional detect going
T's bloodstream this is crazy that go
easy is that poised right now so is left
me they are so calm I now with only 30
seconds on the on the time
[Music]
we still chase time
[Applause]
that was close
oh my dog eyes yo somebody give me a
smoke just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to twitch.tv slash dragon
ball fighters I am rich this is Robin
over and we are here with top 16 of
dragon ball fighters we have our top
eight bracket set topping boozers and
still to go though yeah and this next
one is gonna be a battle of two people
that curse us with dabs yesterday first
starting off the day at noon yesterday
nak yellow was out of character I was
very taken aback because he did make it
all the way in winters and chill just
recently yeah so it's a super noon
earlier on in top 16 but you know who's
very much aesthetic is the dab it's cool
bye yeah if there's anyone that's gonna
get wild and do something silly for the
camera it's gonna be this man right here
and look at them we have the camera I
was saying yesterday this man looks like
somebody that should be playing captain
captain ginyu definitely I can't
remember if he used to play ginyu or not
but yeah that's definitely his type of
character is he gonna yawn and put his
arm around nack y'all can week I mean I
guess if you're trying to court nack
yell that's the way to do it I guess
right
oh the snow is here the kill said I need
to kill say Janaki and Sonic to all get
Quba through the wall maybe well maybe
if we see that then you know Cooper will
ascend but if he's not gonna do the wall
I need him to put away the day we shall
see though Cooper always light-hearted
but very much focused when it comes to
the end game aspect he's very much one
that attacks the mental game of his
opponent always likes to play the game
outside the game as well right that's
why he has all these theatrics plains of
the camera does it not only because you
know that's not person he is but it also
gets it his opponents head if it let's
say or if the opponent likes it it's a
mind game sir most definitely and
you know he's the only person our top 16
rocking trunks he's like I saw that
sneaky dab yeah I also hid right yeah
yeah so definitely a unique team
unorthodox but mad and the two out of
three set against cool buddy he's an
extremely dangerous player he's a very
wild very much in your face he's willing
to swing at any given moment and it's a
super hard to deal with especially if
you'll have any matchup experience he
was gonna have to make sure he does not
just get baited into a super - from hit
yeah and I almost forgot but kuba did
defeat knock yell at thunderstruck so
we're gonna have the hit in the bar
knocking on the trunks over for kuba and
we got a kid buu the Gohan adult and
Goku GT for Nakia this will be an
interesting battle and look at the rust
on his stick he did I hear saying
yesterday he did say he found his stick
at a junkyard excuse me
yeah yeah he told me we're playing some
casuals and he told me I found this
stick at a junkyard and rebuilt it
that's definitely something Google would
do all right starting out trying to get
in his face already you see him
challenging both assist not Gail
actually called out bones the Gohan and
the GT go at the same time and they both
got smacked in the mouth
oh okay oh okay
great time to tag in Gohan but he's
gonna DP through that get himself out of
that corner try to yeah I love that
early challenge will not be all right
there and as he lands from the GT go
places-- he gets a hit with the insulin
err - jump em yeah those very clean jump
eating up there what's it gonna be in
the corner
Oh jabs and coax him out of that changes
oh wow he got caught trying to maneuver
at the super - it's no smash property
the other side la piel was so taken
aback that he got cross under that he
just got caught with the dragon rush
yeah you get the sword flip was on the
other side and was right into the dragon
ride nice spark and I try and giving
this whole medicine you can Crouch under
that 5 s which is why this 2h was
starting up but the GTO who catches it
yeah that converging from now he'll is
beautiful and he gets the hit again just
from the tippy tip of its toes I love
the sweets amuses at three age into the
level of woe and ink to hit who as well
wants it to that potent point character
back in the game
Wow the jump agent stuff the super -
great stuff from nakiye convert off the
gold on it says snap and get hit noses
character is a problem but sparking from
kuba here oh you haven't then jumps on
th stance but just keep swinging kuba
finally finds the hit on the kid boom
and I thought at one point now L had a
good match of experience against its
character when sonic box playing thank
you but not anymore the character has
been forgot by a lot people yeah Cooper
still rocking it's a great success
though again third place overall at
thunderstruck incredible performance
then we're gonna make top eight here and
loser side great super - in confirming
off the G key go key beam there a snap
in Bardock yes we are goes for the jump
light light trial lock them down to give
little blocky instant air - makes up but
again it's very hard to lock loop it
down and condition in nice empty law
yeah I like that a feel oh they're a
great choice of movement therefore not
yo you're gonna have three bars here
gonna go into the Kamehameha
interesting seeing how people respond to
this plenty of meter on his side but he
gets counter he woke up trying to press
buttons did not pay off
don't do that again stock yell
especially with his level up Gohan
summon bars on deck now all I feel like
it's just one of those characters
sometimes you do have to jump around on
it he manages to find the hit on knife
yells go on here I'm not gonna spend the
bar go wait until he gets that next pit
but will he have the chance nice side
switch so smart knock yeah all with the
hands in his pockets like orange Cassady
that's going to be it for not yells go
hard and we are sitting up just GT Goku
already in this first game for Nash yell
against Zubaz hit I would say who was
hit is probably his strongest character
oh I do not know his age I just come
from universe 6 you probably need it
here my man GT Gulf was not from any
university I began bring a bag yeah
you're right
we're not gonna kill all right knock
yell able to seal the first game
definitely a little scary for money in
there kuba of course relentless with
that hit trying to make a comeback but
knock yell maintaining the composure
still in the first game that's scary for
him pretty scary place to be it feel
like it's even scarier when hit has an
assist behind - but not yells gonna
secure the first hit here with his kid
food just from an assists looking up all
the way to the corner almost 50% gone
here gets another hit too much shrine to
press buttons or something there yeah
most definitely try to maneuver out to
wiggle out as he likes to put it
Oh each Mystic Falls you're good to do
nothing he tried to extend the combo
further to get that kill Sparky said
they'd call it it's gone yeah just like
that not be able to complete control -
hold on
[Music]
all right well kuba be able to find his
footing get him in here with hit
not before you see swing without autumn
I'm on the ground looks like he was
trying to bed out super - there I
thought do the code you can't condition
this man even go to the Auto Club
overall attack to get the wall bounce
and the trunks and them out now what's
the mix here to keep yourself safe there
try the side swap it gets caught all
he's doing work all I did good does
cover the oppressive buyers he's gonna
lose his hip because of it I wonder if
he was trying to do the parry there and
like think he was gonna get it off the
time today I think he told me it's for
prints yeah it's not it's not it's then
so gg-go could just happy advantage
there but I think you're right that it
is most likely what he was trying for
who would level three no doesn't apply a
pressure mix-up afterwards an oculist
the wrong tack Wow try some fastball but
he was too far for the first hit of five
out to connect so cool oozing or
interrupt there for a second - because I
think he was trying to do something with
go on but he found locked up yet all
punished yeah 2h on the other side
experience I feel like it's go on
normally left off pretty quickly but he
didn't know I liked the downtown that
yes I swear she beautiful and he's not
gonna go with a little over here rather
just give the level three with Kid Buu
and the hard knockdown if it works it
works
hooba only down to his drums one
character away from being eliminated
find that option from Nakia right there
going one overhead and then stomp some
out low pop Cooper press a bun you see
the counter notification once again
notice the bail others point to bars on
deck that means Cooper's living 6 a.m. I
like that make him block up to the up
tech does catch the back - Oh beautiful
wakeup timing variation from Hanafi oh
there and they guess the cross of law
looks like it's gonna be too old to the
boy and he'll be on top a looser side
with the go harder pokes
hooba dabbing for us one last time
please don't ever do it again
good stuff Tsukuba he will fall short of
top eight this time around but you think
it third please over at thunderstruck so
you know he got a nice amount of points
there
Nakia does redeem has lost the Cooper at
thunderstruck here it first attack in
Puerto Rico yeah and I think he redeemed
it pretty well like that was very
convincing especially that second games
knock y'all really dominating that time
and making sure up there yeah yeah
managed to do without like a level up
Gohan so he talks about how potent that
kid buu point is so I feel like as long
as he's got that on deck with the two
assists he doesn't need level up
anything to get the job that he's been
doing so well like since the beginning
of the game with Kid Buu because I
remember the first time I seen na ki
I'll play Dragon Ball was that final
round last year when they had all the
matches on stream and I just remember
seeing him and I was like who is this
guy he is destroying people yeah yeah
it's cool that na ki also doing well
because as you said he was one of the
first faces of Dragon Ball fighters
right even a during the very first
closed beta he was a streaming I think
he was streaming a lot at the very first
close but as well just putting out a lot
of tech really exploring the game he was
the one I pax he was going to all these
events to play it early he's really been
one of the original grinders of the game
one of the original like pioneers of the
meta and how it's been shaped over the
years so great stuff to nakiye again I
say years but it's only been a year and
a half really of the Dragon Ball
Fighters lifespan two years yeah what it
would be like the two year birthday on
in January January 26 January 6 January
26 and now up on stream in the losers
side we have el padre
el padre grande shakes the hero of spain
indeed he felt the subatomic savers who
is in top eight winterside yesterday but
of course you can never count shanks out
as soon as he fell to the loser bracket
we all figured he was still a favorite
to make top eight still capable of
making grand finals and taking the whole
tournament but now he's got to go
through the kills saves I'm not sure how
the kill estate feels about this matchup
up against shanks but we're gonna see
how he's gonna play it so I feel like
shanks is gonna be trying to bring in
Broly too fuzzy his team has like a
really good option with Android 18 being
able to fuzzy and also adult go on adult
go on oh yeah Ken fuzzy so shanks is in
a good position there if he can
definitely get really early because that
is one of the kill sages strongest
characters I think super Saint Goku is
just Super Saiyan Goku on his team it's
nothing special for her to kill sage but
his main shell here to get rid of is his
team Gohan and the burly yeah
Goku acts as the beam assists Ryan
sounds very strong but besides that to
kill sages Goku is not like something
you have to super worry about you have
to worry about just the powerup that all
these Goku players seem to get when he's
the last character alive but besides
that chain should be fine yep if you got
to kill sage on this let's see those to
kill freak gets in chat and if you have
I'll pave shanks let's see you already
know those Spanish flags with the
genki-dama
and you already know those are being
flooded in the chat shanks we're gonna
make top 8 here does have to go through
the loser sided do it in he's got to get
through the kill sage I like this book
here
eighteen on point but he is playing go
on on point for this start of this match
probably because my assumption is
Android 18 relies so much on 17 assists
it's probably harder for her to get 17s
if that one there's square button to
worry for the teen gohan to Laura
through the live button in this game
kind of watch out for all the Auto combo
stuff coming your way does block the
legs here I tried to DP this is the
cover of wow I love that I love to paint
from the DP they're super awesome mark
hit the kill stage trying to punish him
oh and then punishes the reflect does do
with 5l but he's got enough meter on
deck to kill him regardless bring them
down you have dragon rush extension here
make sure to build the Octomom meter
before getting the kill and bringing in
Android 18 it's a little bit safe for
her to come out now now the team go on
is put to rest yeah and the kill stage I
mean he's got suit or excuse me
Crowley's got such a big heart box right
now 17 is most definitely gonna be
clipping up and I like the use of the
heavy 17 assists here not gonna allow
the kill team pull out that weaknesses
very smart we're gonna snap in go for
the 17 assists here the
medium supremacist early sparking here
from to kill sage know if this being a
free use right now or L here getting
blown up
people accept it if he has to yeah
that's plenty because this was on
cooldown right so the girl's name you
couldn't call it even if you wanted to
I know I just love it that's so can into
the show because there is the episode
where their fight and he says that he'll
let her fight Vegeta but no stuff in if
you have to yeah I love it it's all good
the way they implemented I was getting
little stuff like that yeah they really
think really care the kill/save making
some work here one gonna see whether
free he's worth up
well thanks Sparky one at the corner man
he thought he was gonna come out with a
dragon rush but now shanks max them in
the mountains that 5m good distance on
that Android 18 5m stomp them down yes
can I get another level up yeah
potential unholy
he is mystic right now completely absorb
the incident air - double axe handle
with the 18 assists again very excited -
shakes right now and if shanks does pull
this win one thing I would like to see
to kill say that just - is that 18
barrier gar cancel that's unfortunate
for the kill stage her her light her
light is faster it used to be 7 frames
and now it is 6 frame indeed shakes
offering all of the hand warmers again
we just saw him post something Hearst on
Twitter it was like gamer goo and it's
like you're sweaty first sweaty hands
he's hot reaching down right there
trying to keep the moisture off the head
nice and dry it is a little humid here
in Puerto Rico yeah ok once ago - a
Spain is probably destroying twitch chat
right now has extension with a brawling
be able taken to the corner here this is
a big problem for the kill station the
first games is an output as much damage
as possible man okay yeah you kill stage
making quick work here rapido min tape
Oh clips are there yeah it's so good you
just cover her full combo oh my goodness
put that 17 assists away yeah but it's
sweet I sleep
the dragon rush nice advantage from
shanks yeah I do like that man I've got
him out of that corner positioning but
still have to deal with this tank may
all these raw tags are going to snuff
down and then become a house as well
yeah thanks he'll adjust when doing here
not I think that loss of momentum at the
beginning has actually hurt shanks
pretty pretty decent here and let's
beginning of this game for sure we got
keep blasts on deck okay
yeah but with a double level one that
has a dead Gohan blow through to regen
too much longer running out
yeah incredible start for the kill sage
Kripa was really asked for a better one
able to kill off the Gohan or waste the
sparker chinks as well but where's the
signature Android 18 still the elbow is
gonna get a level three good stuff from
chasing him but that meter penalty not
allowing him to get the second bar he
does get so good shakes right there
cause the Android 17 out actually sparks
up sort of kills sage get some life back
[Music]
to the corner five bars like Zach this
is definitely a Democrat and the kill
state has all these characters most
death and the kill stage now has a bully
back in as well
big neutral control in this character
right huge bun good he blasts good
projectile game in general this is gonna
be a big humpback and just with that
grab that's gonna do a little bit of
damage here to shanks this he has a lot
of work to put in if he wants to take
this checking game on the co-state and
it is looking very very
yeah looking over can go three level
ones and once more
and it kills they've started out with a
big age Ryan young condition Chang's to
jump out of that command throw since he
got hit by a previously this time just
commit to the heavy button and again
it's a similar startup riot the closed
fist means is gonna punch you the open
palm he's gonna grab you but it's very
hard to distinguish between the two in
the moment absolutely now I would expect
nothing less for this to be going to a
game three between these two they're
both Titans they both always
consistently I mean typically at most
these events they've been making top
eight yeah for sure of course the kill
stage again coming off that
thunderstruck victory Shane's always
performing super well especially in 2019
he's really coming to his own one of the
premier players in the entire world for
Dragon Ball fighters not just the EU I
mean it is one one here and this is for
losers top a qualifier I know that's
hard to believe but shanks did falling
subatomic savers we saw apology man
defeat the kill stage so one of these
guys will not be in hot baby
ole-ole I think I was actually been sold
by the Kelso's there later here doesn't
make any bank off of the sparking that
early and it's already gone yeah it's
unfortunate only seven seconds right
when you get the level one sparking here
and build much meaner off of it because
he used the Vantage and now shanks in
complete control snap them out bring in
this beam assist block on the empty long
he has a lot of Gohan experience
obviously living with nakiye watch the
fastball clashes and then go to the end
afterwards huge playing from the kill
stage okay great except not the assist
there
going into wine we want to go to out
helps gone already from going just like
that and he takes the opportunity there
take it though they're gonna get blown
up for that one are we gonna see it
really sparking here from shakes
yeah after spending that bar the
potential at least you didn't want to
give up the character but desperate
super gaskets to age jump cancel the
second hit the oh that would have been
it so hard to recognize that in the
moment
Rolly is running rough shot all over
this team I'll try to get the command
grabbing the sky while the key black
chase them down
dragon roads will do enough damage the
armor the theory does not connect lariat
Express to the rod side man rolling us
all over the place to age James can't
figure out how to get past the big man
he still living with his goal Honda all
the unblockable and then hello Wow
despite all that shakes is actually
really good the first character kill and
it's gonna be on the Brawley he's gonna
go
huge break huge break for shanks right
there well done but still things are
looking rough on his side lots of health
gone yeah get hit by that heat go on DP
Android 17 not connecting there for
block wow he actually blocked just in
time write that yourself walking forward
anticipating the cross up recognizing
the super dashes on though lock them
down the pink ohon exit kill say it's
gonna bring out that heavy 17 assists to
make sure he cannot call his emphases
those super dances through great move
here for shakes he's gonna get a level
three he's not gonna spend it just quite
yet the black he didn't believe in it's
only thing you would actually get the
ground hit I like the back off there got
to be careful against this character
goes for the love all he's able to
reflect the 17 and system is what
afterwards on the head there old bug the
opening there
gonna be a lot of damage here her shank
he wants to bring it down got the
sidewalks but great defense here from to
kill sage go through the grab gets blown
up for it wow great challenge with the
kill sage right there you saw this
caught up with a command throw not on oh
he's got five bars on the heck yeah you
can extend this right all the way
through all yes wants to get rid of the
Android 18 now we're two characters
apiece that's character to take out if
you're gonna take out one of shakes his
characters but he still does have that
go on even though he is paint caused by
it thread long distance it to the level
three Holy Smoke so smart yeah it's
gonna get a good set up after this what
is he gonna do micro walk out into the
auto combo huge star for the kill sage
here
[Music]
enough to kill here level one level I'm
gonna get some that blue held back while
dad comes back out and just a go on
hanging on by a thread left here huge
damage all those level ones it literally
took to the last hit to get him now
changes dust down to the pixel Gohan up
he blasts trying to control that space
as best as he can this is so scary for
shapes to be in terrifying hit by the
staggered key blast there you hate to
see it the run for el padre and shortly
love Santa yeah the kills sage able to
secure his spot in top eight looser side
taking down shanks so we felt it both
subatomic savers and the kill stage here
at this tournament I'm sure we're gonna
see shanks at the Spain saga for sure
we'll probably see him at the finals as
well as the Japan saga so shanks is
tournament season is most definitely not
over just yet
absolutely and I just saw a little back
hat hug from fellow EU brother when as
he was coming off the stage you know
giving some love to shanks you know he
made a great run here but that doesn't
mean he use out just yet we do have rmz
coming up next against no commie for a
loser side battle and then looks like we
I think still have yeah Hachi collar
versus Wawa which should be a very
exciting match to determine our top our
last of our top eight I believe I
believe that's it
yeah I believe that is the last
qualifying match it's going to be coming
up after this one as you mentioned
armsie from the United Kingdom up in the
EU going up against no commie no economy
looking very good yeah I think he's
wearing the bright green hat today no
it's blue today very bright still I was
it's a electric blue yeah most def thing
he's got a classic Adidas tracksuit get
up to man on Z looks swagger for days
dude I wish I was wearing my track C
right now well it's like pinkish Burke
although like technically a shade of
pink it's not like uh-huh
it's the torn-up our Android 18
tracksuit you right you right but yeah
this this should be a fun match again no
call me plate really well even today in
his match that he lost he still was
playing pretty relatively strong yeah I
thought in the first game against some
atomic he looked real good right but
some of the top just got the download
started at getting the momentum with his
unorthodox team and no comedies couldn't
really find the answers but rmz a little
bit more of a traditional team Ryan we
got the team go Honda Bartok and the GT
Goku and I think that that winter side
spot that went to subatomic was very
well deserved especially knocking out
Titans like shanks and you know no
commie oh yeah for sure
so big ups to subatomic you'll see him
later and top eight winner side again we
are at the last to top eight losers
qualifying matches well first one no
commie
versus our NZ and we're letting the
intros rock here baby
there we go teen gohan powering up that
Super Saiyan level - how is he the most
intimidating character in the game yeah
poor respect on teen Gohan name
the look in his eyes his fears he never
named is the strongest yeah yeah
yeah mr. Gohan's a family man he's not a
savage like mr. teen gohan we're looking
for that opening here right now those
clarifications gonna 2h after that
Mystic Falls Center the messenger early
you want mystic ball recklessly you're
gonna get antsy at for it oh and then
punishes the local ex attempt start off
of the 2mm as well so that means kid
who's gonna die he's going right into a
level 1 hair going in the Bartok level 1
and that's gonna be enough to kill
didn't even need the third bar now he's
got Bart on point teen gohan just got a
scratch a chip damage on him okay going
on the offense here both a sister down
though trying to stack do this presently
when he gets the hint
don't call me just didn't want to keep
blocking there yeah
nice set up shop with the teen gohan
assist and they got the air - big sub
cracking all calm here on the head
keeping their business ended even longer
going for the knockdown gonna leave it
at that's not going to level three but
gets hit by that auto proper for me to
go through there he's got five bars on
deck yeah so we're gonna see the spirit
bottle court oh no he was doing there
yeah unfortunate he's gonna get a chance
to running right back no we couldn't -
forward enough to get the avocado oil
that means a dead TT Goku - genki-dama
setups failed and that's a dead
character I feel like that's homely to
get tilted but it feels like he is a
little bit on tilt right now in there
are NZ gonna get the knock down the corn
here we can get the level 3-wood teen
gohan as well the hard knockdown no
economy yeah be thinking about spark
there wasn't the reflect off I know I
feel like he's gonna try and save it for
the next gift that he gets maybe or like
at the end but this is at least look
good spot to be in you did get that
dragon rush this is gonna be a dead
Bartok he's gonna have these level 3
uses it those four bars even with that
slow recovery that's gonna happen but
this is gonna kill so I don't think this
will apply exactly either one foot meter
penalty it's done yeah once we get the
round over it's like a sis cooldown or
anything like that right it just
refreshes once we get a new round so I
like the red like the reservation at
this point Chris barking sometimes I
don't believe in it but this is gonna be
painful opened rung the commo
let's just say you got a smart now he
gave me a second chance at life
don't throw it away that could have been
it right there for our Z but this could
still be it right here
it's hard to say no he's just gonna go
for the knock down here which is good
because if he gets one more set up
that's a dead goat oh oh - ba-gawk hot
pressing buns a little bit late there no
economy challenges successfully yeah no
commies gonna have to make use of
whatever sparking is left here gonna get
you know what's he gonna go for goes for
the jump medium into the dragon rush
great tech there from arm Z yeah it's
gonna be pretty hard so they didn't have
the GT go Lewis is available to get down
and get the super going but arm Z does
take the first game anyway he just get
some of the toes mm-hmm cat's toes to L
city now arm Z one match away from their
top eight loser side no problem you saw
them fall and the first game and
subatomic savers let's see how are you a
progression in a set where he loses the
first game some of the nerves you know
from playing this new team that sees
he's a really good player but he's not
in similar with this team you know like
we were saying he placed it in for 21
and always quick over the black as well
yeah he played Samus you for a while oh
yeah I forgot his the monster standing
he got it with a 3m lock into the 5m
right there you gotta be careful the
long legs of kit blue using the level 3
already had those three bars build up
possible Cobb
it's the mix gonna be all just trucks
with me jab right their arms you can
preserve the health and the team go home
[Music]
late on it sparking here from no pani
though challenge it gets the vanish you
can see the mutability kicking in only
for a little while though it's gone now
on adults a one-bar with the goal to
damage still not enough oh I like I can
manage to get a team don't want out of
there but gets hit it was a dull with
bar knock yeah arms he looking a
challenge with the 2l right there
thought no problem II would stagger the
pressure but instead instant air - all
right I like that reflect got herself
out of clerical area you don't candy
bean this is Dragon Ball what are you
doing
just kidding but you don't can t be
kidding about as always both assist
available for a no Tommy but he doesn't
shoot through the spin I don't want
interesting
can he hold on right now this is great
defense but oh it challenges it
yeah no commies swinging in from a
distance when he was outside the range
to actually make Bartok block and of
course the rains on that 5l from rmz
always gonna beat on the girl all right
I like this it's not gonna quite through
the damage as it feels down character
but still gonna give him a good set up
after okay doesn't get the head off of
it but still he is on the offense got
both assist back up gonna get to
pressure for a little bit longer
dragging this one a great guard cancel
there from no copy
boom players from a lot I respect those
- forwards no commies the one that does
attempt to strike oh come on not gonna
reach tries to go through the knock down
there Oh staggers no trying to catch
arms he slipping he's content to block
it out so far and I can about to rock
out
so some ball but he just tries to the
dragon rush out the nice text wasn't
able to convert off at that cheeky Goku
beam there both players are trying to
find their opening right now plank very
patient very respectful towards each
other as well yeah super neutral heavy
match here in games here oh he actually
got clipped by the - Evelyn juggled what
the kid Louis's yeah that was very smart
search they're gonna go into the level 3
both players still have all three
characters right now they're like no
papi can big two level three arrived
because there's been a whole it's been
so rare to actually get hits in this
match if you gotta make them count when
you do yeah with the same thing - is the
delay - am catching rmz I like the
vanish to vanish but asserting itself on
this offense though players just so
patient but he finds that low opening
and gets rid of the GT Goku on arms
these team yeah it was a counter hit as
well as arms he's swinging after that
dump pop off oh great Ross right there
probably cross the protection but man if
it wasn't a tremendous walk to eight
there - so I wonder if he thought that
nope.avi was gonna vanish there
okay here we go we're gonna drag them
into the corner yeah good to go into
bars on the three I like the choice of
it it's gonna give them some mix-up
potential here in the corner right there
again yeah you try to like bar canceling
strings like that usually and then when
it comes to the key blasts into the 5h
you look to reflect out of the blocks
that are key blasts and then I get to
hit by the 5h rather than reflecting the
key blasts itself reflect their arms big
commitment on his side no Tommy's gonna
make him pay for it level one's all he
will need and I was gonna bring in his
bleeding teen gohan yeah this would be
the comeback of the century right now if
he's to come back from this therefore
with the gumball backing them up nice
reflect afterwards to get rid of it I
agree I think that's a great reflect on
that I got Paul that's not the first
time you've done that either I've seen
him do it a couple times which is one of
the best ways to deal with that pressure
now and I believe it's because he's
committing to that reflects right he's
trying to do it in blocks then and then
getting clip low I think he also just
maybe it was a little given up I feel
like it's really hard to still even as a
pro player I mean I don't quote me on
this because I am NOT but I'd like to
ask one of them when you get to a point
where you're that low do you feel like
you're about to give up do you feel like
all hope is lost
you oughta compost swing in and we
started with a second hit of is let's go
I'm like a medium nice damage okay I
think one of my favorite things so far
about the these two players and their
matchup here is the patience between two
of them both again I cannot stress with
enough playing very
against each other considering certain
characters on each other's team yeah and
armsie the patient was paying off right
there keep blasts while no economy tried
it as well but since the key blast to s
of a hip who take something I'm the sky
and goes over the head he was able to
punish it again just trying to play that
game catches the raw attacker the super
- it was all super solid plays and
Warren Z so fought and letting them back
into the car with the dragon rush give
me that kid buu back and that's a great
area to snap from - because I feel like
the lower you snap before the faster
you're gonna have a chance to get
another mixed up one hair snapping
somebody is exactly get some land oh my
goodness I'm thinking lock of the
sparking in the air and that means you
are not at Plus brains my friend you are
negative frames then he screams at him
yeah no commie just committing to it
arms you with a great hold on the
reflect tool bars that's all he's gonna
need yeah he is [ __ ] up too so a
little bit stronger right here yeah
hello lariats it okay goes for low goes
for the 6m I'm gonna have to hold that
respect
show some respect man all this Tiger
pressure bar Z a freaking set oh just as
I say that he swings and gets will
punish the dragon flirting face up with
some five life yeah feel good feeling
when you see it though it's not gonna
lie here we go we're going to the game
oh yeah you're so cheery now he's good
spirit Bob Bardock is out the game now
no comments doing his due diligence with
the GT Goku okay backing off gonna keep
blasts Frank by that opening does find
the opening with the diagonal key black
run in the legs go back off gg-go see
bean out there going into the heavy legs
all right back soccer there's no longer
his turn but gets hot in the air to air
beautiful air to everybody cannot
convert I think you got hot try to think
about which confer to do think about
that one just keep swinging level 3 as
well powered up version I believe this
is going to be a dead GT go through
sometimes read red eye shadow powers you
up oh excuse me
and then the second over half the block
in the first a 2h in the air that's
brutal but no coffee still looking
strong here God Super Saiyan Goku great
character to still have is your last
character if you're gonna have any yes
the bang right team Gohan for rmz is one
combo away from death so no economy
could definitely do this however arms he
gets the first here imagine the one time
that Goku gets out range when he's
trying to have a little poke battle
against somebody right yeah I don't
think he was using to em I think he was
using not - oh nice blocking the 6m back
dashes afterwards because he arms he
just chasing it down the trees yeah
interesting challenge like an advantage
I like the respect from rmz he was like
he was gonna let no commie take his turn
after that we talked about it before
anything after the dragon rush taking
the air is due to Goku you gotta respect
the beam on the fall here and this could
be the end here for no commie I know he
was really expecting to make top aid so
I do feel for him but great performance
here from rmz and great respect from
both of these players toward each other
that was some great dragon ball that we
just saw in the big ups to rmz from the
UK making top a looser side so you'll
see him more later on you'll see no
economy hopefully and maybe one of the
saga Spain or Japan hopefully both and
as he continues that campaign to get to
the finals well done from both of our
players and now we have arrived the last
match of top eight qualifiers we're
going to have tachi Cowell from Japan
vs. Wolof youth France itself this is a
really exciting one so this is the other
EU player that we could still see in our
top eight voila
definitely favored to make it while with
just one was it eg wgx PGX I believe out
there and the EU and it was quite it was
quite a celebration over there when he
won so I'm sure everyone from home is
watching right now I'm getting excited
for Wawa but I'm also really excited for
talk to call or to still not be out yet
tot Chicago coming all the way from
Japan mostly other Japanese players
probably sitting on a decent amount of
points right now this really needed to
come out to this one especially with Red
Bull Japan coming up and Red Bull Spain
so yeah big chances to get points there
but ah chicawa try to get every point
you can possibly get right so he's here
in Puerto Rico at first attack get the
powerup candy going real quick yeah I
think he's had a little bit of trouble
the last couple events here I think
especially finding a team that worked
again for him because you know he was
like kind of the hipster player at first
you know playing hit Frieza and Android
18 for a while at the combo breaker we
saw that
and evolve - now what is his team
dropping all three of those carrot them
all on the injured reserve
he's a brought to the starting line at
the team going on the GT Goku and me
Yamcha he's definitely looking to win at
the character select screen however his
signature character Frieza was the
character that sent him to losers at the
helm of Chris G I think that's karma
karma or maybe Chris she found all seven
dragonballs and his Frieza used them to
wish himself a little bit taller
yeah and that was the advantage that he
had on him Chris holler Frieza
maybe his Frieza was taller than dr.
Kawas Frieza I mean but being taller
this games not good that's true maybe
maybe it's drunk maybe he shrunk himself
just to like be like GT Goku sized
truncus hitbox that we didn't see all
right we got Wawa coming up here though
let's talk about wala so you know
obviously a connoisseur of you know base
Goku right yeah I mean I think of Dragon
Ball fighters in general right he played
so many members in the cast at egx we
saw him play some doji - what is this he
was a button check team from tachi cowl
right here the curl in the majin buu in
the Vidal I mean maybe he's just gonna
show us some Crillon tech that we have
never seen here maybe it's some special
rock throws I was about to say cuz the
wah wah does have a lot of the castle
under his belt right like I said we've
seen him play so many teams but of
course is the main business his main
chicken is what I think we're gonna get
right now
yeah his go on is really good - I really
grew up seeing this go on so one thing
that I didn't agree with yesterday that
was in the game that he sent got sent to
losers with was he switched from his
goal one after doing it was not yelled
at sent to two losers and the one thing
I didn't agree with was he got rid of
Gohan and switched in Bardock and it in
his barn oka just exploded yeah it was
weird because he didn't really lose the
first game by much so his goal one was
doing a good job there was no need for
it honestly yeah man we're seeing the
adult Gohan back in action up against
Itachi Khan was in his first game and
yeah well just in general I think it's
been one of the most inspiring
Dragonball Fighters players in 2019 he's
just brought incredible tech to the
table in general his decision-making and
adjustments are out of this world again
I'm very surprised
see him and losers top a qualifying
match it's definitely I think if there
was any upsets of the of this tournament
so far that is definitely one of the
bigger ones yeah
the only thing is that wah-wah did
loosen Akio last year at UFA so na Kiev
doesn't have his number besides that I
think just with how much of an overall
favorite wah-wah was it isn't Vita upset
Texas for a second all right
Hachiko being very respectful he was
facing trying to make his move in though
throwing out these key blasts fair
enough yeah both of these players know
that tournament life is on the line here
rice and no one's trying to make any
reckless maneuvers Dec but he's not
gonna have the chance to use it just yet
talk to call upon the hit are we gonna
see a snap out we are the character to
bring in here and get rid of as fast as
you can which he is already make quick
work of is that based okay yeah it's
gonna be the character talking I was at
least matchup experience against is one
of the most deadly characters and wall
was hands now he's gonna play the snap
man I'm forced him to play one character
at a time and we're gonna spark up super
- though not a good place for wala to be
sitting that especially after he's in
that sparking it's running out exactly
he's gonna be able to get him down here
you another snap out that's walking did
nothing to get wha-wha out of this
defensive momentum that - part of
hesitate turn and then got that to em
hey brazen GG Goku here - to end this oh
man he is man no more face goku for wall
wall we got that level three Spirit Bomb
I said I was gonna follow it up no
dragon rush necessary just gonna play it
nice and safe all the way through number
one
one and that is a dead base Goku voila
peon very made quick work of hereby
tachi column that locks to Christie's
Frieza really set the fire here for Taj
Paulo nice bar cancel the legs Allah
tryna get some offensive momentum back
yes I can't staggering the strings
you're gonna do because you don't really
see MVP that much
devices reversal it's usually like the
level three right not really the DP 14
Gohan another overhead open up a lot of
meter being built here but dead Gohan if
you can place the column bunny most
definitely will dragon rush DP into
level one just needs one more to finish
it just like that
Takizawa barely touched right now a
little bit help take it away from his
team going on but that is it is this
thing on sparking wah-wah it's a danger
here of losing this first game that was
a signal extension yatra you see pushing
the opponent away punishes the whip
reflect with the dragon flash fist all
right I like the guard cancel out of the
corner almost got caught there with that
air-to-air gonna get hit by the Doha oh
my god yeah the team Ohana says column
then he converts off of it that means
that wawas Goku is dead and touching
Gong overwhelmingly takes the first game
he is hungry for those points I don't
know what was in that candy that he ate
but he is powered up he was a bulldog
wall on that game is all over him maybe
it's gone maybe it's drawn on gum yeah I
mean he's still chewing so that's either
a hearty candy or something you know
maybe for a secret Japanese tech that we
have not seen yet with candy yeah I know
I know super news always trying to be on
the latest latest hip tech to where the
Japanese players are doing outside of
the game like the the speed reading that
go Ichi does the the eye drops the
Rosie's the Candy's I still don't know
about those eye drops
I heard it's literally like putting mint
in your eyes and I could go bad them I
cannot fathom that cringe it's like you
know the feel of like brushing your
teeth that's how it feels on your eyes
but it burns a little bit more I don't
like that I can go from and 1080p to 4k
what you want that but but what if
there's lag 4k TVs have a lot of loud
not when you take the road Aziz you
think go II geez gonna get sponsored by
someone with lag never that you know
maybe go eat Jesus that God like it
doesn't matter that's fair that's true
he is that God line he is a God I came
to now magic how was it took the first
when we got wala switching to the cell
right we saw him switch his character
after losing the first game yesterday
but man hopefully this cell does more
work in the Bardock necessarily position
that we want to see wallow in right now
especially for those who are fans of
Wawa gets hit by that unfortunate yeah I
like the idea of starting selling this
because you don't have to deal with the
fuzzy setups on the incoming but man he
already snapped them out nice dragon
rush techno all are gonna get a chance
to play with his baseball no yeah we
need that wall was special there three
bars already built phrase you lent me
your heads down the water spirit ball a
long tries to counter the abroad cancel
while the elbow coming through alley you
to himself
and the crowd is going wild over to
baseball he's so entertaining man nice
Marco from toxic cow it doesn't want to
take any more of this pressure it's wild
to because when this character came out
everyone was complaining at first they
were like another go through but it is a
very exciting Goku they did a really
great job at making them unique
absolutely [ __ ] Colin ends up being
the head after whipping the last name is
Otto problem just going right back into
it while although late on a punishment I
agree with the sparking here cell in the
corner exact place we want to beat great
use of the sparking with advantage to
I was beautiful holding the - getting
that on the other side now the solar
kamehameha with a long dock down to
knock down right into that level three
Oh got caught back yapping with that tag
huh alright snapping in basecoat who
knows his character is a problem you try
getting with a hesitation to em again
but Wawa more discipline this time and
then punish is the whip reflector to
Emma's own I don't love it here we go
it's ending with the beam going right
into the pie okay beautiful here take
some towards the corner don't be upset
you're gonna stay on the ground I'm
gonna command bro you and this is gonna
be I believe enough yeah I do the energy
field you got this
voila coming back from that first game
looking better with this cell
once he gets cooking on that base goku
man's hard to stop him yeah but you know
yeah i think if all the baits go through
really like so great and all but while
i'll face go through yes we we hey
that's definitely what was cooking in
this game too
now jumping over now Sasha Cowell with a
solo Yamcha I mean we've seen him come
back with his character before nice
perfect attack punished doesn't have a
sparking but still a big damage starter
and he has just this on deck if he can
extent mess here we go hug them hug it
out boys otra yeah too much hits done on
that to actually get the commander out
the words I love the defense here and
the great reflect off of that for a
little bit of damage but he's trying to
get this base Goku done with okay great
texture from wah-wah base Goku playing
offense right into the dragon rush to
wala you maniac yeah Sachi Cowell was
looking for the - OS right there right
he - directly into the arms usually the
daschle was you press the button lay
enough to actually get the tech on the
dragon run but not successful talk to
Colin that time it is one up here in our
last match to see who completes our top
page he was doing so much working that
he was making Sachi Cowell a yes brush
the bullet gained the power from it a
people rate you know if he braided it he
might have like a like Jedi powers I was
gonna say yeah that's a mean Jedi rats
alright yeah you know speaking of Rock
Hill he doesn't eat he throws you on his
team so channeling it but he's gonna
find that hit below yeah while waking up
wasn't selling mushrooms perfect
attacking or a bun either way his
counter is brushing the mullet seemed to
do a good job here cuz he's already
coming into this first game strong with
the snap he really wants his base go
through dead though great block on the
low up to the legs in a sense punishes
the whip reflect
Hill over the two elves all right so
wah-wah could have been hurting a bit
more
I thought well I've had it there q but
tatcha call it delayed that next pitch
yeah he was going to be forced into a
fuzzy situation there so Wawa is using
the Spartan to bypass that but he
completes the conversion off the DT go
to assist yeah that GT consistent while
I arrived Taj Mahal is ready for it -
it's got this level three off now and
wallah goes run up and the dragon rush
is gonna be a dead cell no sparking down
to two characters this is not a good
game three so far for Wawa and no damn
and I need to talk to colors life bars
either rush tech again and the reactions
of the young man walk walk the elbow yet
again how you been to himself off the go
to assist oh he's right through it and
again that's something that you're gonna
be conditioned not to really expect the
talk to call because he doesn't really a
lot oh he gives me a falling mix up
again on wawas base Goku here he's got
enough here to kill him off he just
gotta finish the combo and he thaws make
sure he's dead make sure that GT Goku's
on point for this last character as well
Wow while I've got all the leaders in
the world but no other characters no
sparking topic I was super healthy and
the town of the to have opener with a
super - super - is oh that's what
something just said expect to friend to
do but it's working and it gets that
overhead with Mema dragon flash
businessman err - while he was falling
to get that mixup brainstuff level 3
again just trying to widdle this life
part down on wall walk not caring if he
gives up the corner he just wants those
hard knock down I'll try to go back to
the original size doesn't get in that
wall has a window of opportunity
all right voila trying to do what he can
still with what he has left not a lot of
health left
at least he's using some of these bars
yeah like that he's gonna bash them out
of the corner so the level three put
them back in the corner goes in the jump
medium some staggers here almost got a
head did not really commit to it goes
into the dragon rush this is gonna be a
dead GG go to at least so one character
left for him not to have to worry about
here perfectly calculated by law on the
last hit killing off the GT goes only
one meter spent gonna have to be scary
this is the character that I think
really get rid of gibberty Wallace you
can get rid of teen Gohan somehow I
can't believe they're just finishes the
job beautiful stuff toxic I was sneaking
in that insolent air - teen Gohan his
soul fast they can combo off of it with
the legs and he does so touching how a
makes top eight and wah-wah the person I
considered the favorite to take the
entire tournament Falls one game short
on top of here I think we only have one
EU or top eight rmz made it from a UK
who I mean no disrespect to our MZ but
I'm sure shanks and wah-wah or more
favorited to make the top Ethan he shout
out to him that's gonna like you know
he's already on the map and he's been on
the map but this is like you know really
big for him and I think this is really
big to tachikoma taking that I think Taj
Okawa really needed those points really
needed those points he needs the points
and he needs just I think the morale
like boost from these double use right
so I Chicago has been having a lot of
struggles you can see them dancing over
there so Big Ups to him as you see the
way the top a broke down and of course
the top eight is at 6 p.m. you know what
time it is getting real quick Oh
I have my watch on today I did not so I
look at my wrist so it's about two
o'clock here so we're gonna get for our
break here but come back right here on
twitch.tv slash Dragonball Fighters or
for that top eight until then thank you
all for joining us arm Rindge this is
Romanova and we'll see y'all soon